uh let me introduce professors Waits I
am Adrian Liu both of them are our
professors in mechanical engineering
here at Stanford
um both of them are also members of the
mechanics and computation group and have
been working as part of that group in
general on the research behind metal 3D
printing and out of that research has
grown a a course now that they're
offering for the first time the students
and so what I we're going to have a kind
of wide-ranging conversation here today
uh about 3D printing about their
research and about the course but I
thought it would be useful if we started
with a little bit deeper dive into your
into just more about you and your
research interests and we were chatting
beforehand and I had noticed before that
uh both of you started as nuclear
engineers and now here you are in a
mechanical engineering department and
focusing on metal 3D printing so uh
Professor Ty could you just start us off
and talk a little bit about your
background your research and how you got
to
metal 3D printing where you're in how
you got to that interest right
um I guess you know looking back at my
PhD times uh yeah I got my degree in UK
engineering but really we were studying
through the fundamental deformation
mechanisms of metals right so that
actually uh you know that those methods
could be used in the nuclear reactor or
you could use using other applications
right so so over the last 20 years or so
my research has always been on how to
understand the microstructure evolution
of materials and then through that
um how you know we can predict the
properties of materials right uh and and
now the metal 3D printing is basically a
fascinating Arena where basically all of
this will come back and and basically uh
lead to interest and new phenomenons and
new functions
interesting okay so that's great so in
fact there's a study through line to it
from the beginning you've been looking
at kind of the fundamental properties
metals and and predicting the the
structures of those properties of those
events
Professor Lou
well thank you bugs this is very
exciting to be here sharing this webinar
with you and with the audience so I
started also as a nuclear engineer but
my background was in computational solid
mechanics I was trying to simulate the
mechanical behavior of
fluids and solids as you load them right
so this is solving a lot of partial
differential equations in the Computing
and adding a little bit of secret sauce
to say how the material behaves and you
know I I loved mathematics and I loved
analyzing things in that context but
since suddenly a few years ago I precise
in 2015 I I started to help a company
here in the Bay Area
doing meta 3D printing and I realized
then with meta 3D printing you can
actually build what you would ideally
design with the computer so if you know
how to do computational mechanics then
you would say okay how can I build this
structure in the best possible way and
here in method 3D printing you have what
we call free form possibilities you can
essentially build the shape that you
want with few a lot fewer restrictions
that need current manufacturing with
established manufacturing methods I just
fell in love with it and that's how I
started that's fantastic so I want to
come back to that so well in fact maybe
we can start you know just as a
follow-up to that so uh you know you
said you started with metal 3D printing
in 2015 could you give us a broader
overview so when I think of 3D printing
when we were first started talking about
this I think of kind of 90s 2000 like
you know you print a little a little
plastic Eiffel Tower but my understand
and it's used to maybe for a lot of
prototyping rapid prototyping and
organizations but it sounds like a metal
3D printing is relatively new maybe in
the last decade where it's really taken
off can you give us a kind of a broader
overview of you know metal 3D printing
just kind of broadly speaking what is it
and and how is it different from that
you know what I think about when I think
of you know the 90s and the little
desktop 3D printer
so I'll tell you the story that I know I
try to verify this story many times I'm
not sure I couldn't but essentially yes
methodly printing started in 19 1986
mostly for polymers
um and there was a lot of activity in
the early 90s even by one of our
colleagues here Fritz prince in what was
called rapid prototyping my
understanding is that there were a lot
of initial patterns that were preventing
the free development of the technology
that started to fall at the beginning of
the 2010s and that's where a lot of
startups started to develop here and in
Europe and that's how the sort of the
industry flourished and it's still
flourishing right I mean it's still too
early it's still moving moving into the
future essentially can you talk maybe
build a little bit about that so it is
fairly young and may it's not that the
technology hasn't been there but its
availability has really become more
widespread can you talk a little bit
more about
um about that flourishing and and you're
saying it's kind of still at its early
stages what does that mean Liam can you
unpack that a little bit
yes so what happens is that it
essentially we when you 3D print you're
generating a new material it's not the
same material that you cast it's a
different material
and the the material they've generated
depends on the geometry of the part and
the process that you choose to bring
and so there are a lot of uncertainties
on exactly what type of material you get
so if you want to do some nice
decoration for your for your home then
you don't care right but if you want
engineering performance out of it you
will need to understand better what is
happening there and so it takes times it
takes it takes time in engineering to
certify processes to gain the confidence
that you need to use it in in a
situation that you have some
requirements to to me hold on to that so
so this is about what's the difference
right between the metal through the
printing and the Plastics reprinting
that most of us have in our garage right
so sort of from a
sort of just a basic
processing point of view that the the
main difference is that if you want to
print metal you have to mount it and the
melting point is way higher right than
than the plastic so for the plastic you
know printer the melting point is less
than 200 degrees Celsius and if you want
to melt steel uh it's it's more than a
thousand degrees Celsius okay so so
basically there's this enormous so
basically you have to raise the
temperature a huge I mean five times
higher and then it's going to cool down
and so that's one reason why you can't
have your metal 3D printer in your
garage right so you basically have to
have a lab right right
um and in fact you can if I manage we
can make a manager okay between this the
temperature scale of the printing okay
with a scheme okay a ski resort okay
okay so basically you go to your Resort
okay I mean usually there's like that
I don't know very
family-friendly kind of slow over there
that's where I want to go to okay okay
you know it's it's safe and all that but
then there's another one right the peak
is five times higher than this one right
right that's where my kids want to go
but that was kind of very nervous okay
but then if you go all the way up there
right and then you come down and then
but when you come down you're gonna come
down fast right and then the
differently from the skin in skin
basically hopefully every time you come
back you go back to the same spot right
but here
when we go to the same spot that
basically means that it's the same
structure that you're gonna like that
but in you know in 3D printing I think
one of the excitement is that basically
as you come down you have a control at
the right time okay then basically you
can you can control the formation of the
microstructure so that you can end up as
all kinds of microstructures that many
of them are never seen before right and
then you basically as agent was saying
you end up with a
completely different material okay so
that is the challenge of metals really
differently and also the excitement is
being able to sort of tailor or or plan
and create those microstructures can we
have like very very different
microstructure than that before so the
slope for you was the temperature right
right yeah okay so basically the height
I'm talking about this is the
temperature and you go basically you
have to finish the thing cools down very
fast yeah and it goes to a thousand
degrees and then you know probably pass
down to room temperature in like you
know I mean a second and then then this
is the very fast speed yeah so I want to
stay on I want to come back maybe to
some broad level uh things as well but I
do want to stay here because I think
this is a really interesting part of it
when you say that so let's say I I cast
Titanium or something a titanium part
when I'm casting it it's a different
material than when I'm 3D printing it
when inter if we're coming back to
Casting are the same uh I assume to some
extent the same things are at play right
because you have to heat it up to a very
hot level it cools down
is it just that those processes had been
around longer so we understand them
better or is it that um you have less
ability to sort of tweak the parameters
to create those microstructures so I
mean does that make sense
so yeah so this is a really very good
observation right so
first of all let me let me start with
the best way of describing what we are
talking about yeah that they found right
for instance titanium a titanium like
titanium six aluminum 4 Vanadium the
most popular and Allah used for instance
in medical implants
uh so it has you know a concentration of
atoms of titanium of aluminum right and
some other things
so when you cast the the
alloy what you do is you heat it up you
put it in the mold okay you you control
where you are injecting the the the
amount so that you know you know exactly
more or less how it's solidifying okay
and it's solidifies at a very slow right
and it's mostly uniform or you try to
design it with the computer as well to
be uniform
so in that situation you know that the
titanium atoms will go somewhere and
then the aluminum atoms will go
somewhere else
okay when we 3D print things
the turns out that the aluminum and the
Vanadium atoms don't have the chance to
move
to where they should be for what the
alloy was designed to invest it okay
essentially we have the same atoms but
all that differently when we 3D print
them in that sense it's a different
material so a different alloy
essentially same same it depends on how
you Define alloy because aloe you know
it's the same proportion mostly the same
proportional in proportion of the
components but they had organized
differently interesting okay because
precisely you don't have time for the
atoms to accommodate and the lattices
and the grains to arrange themselves
themselves in a way that you would get
in casting so coming back to your
analogy a big difference so even in
casting you you basically that slope is
a shallower slope because the cooling
takes place over a longer period of time
and in in proportions I guess are better
understood whereas with this it's it's
that it's rapidly Cooling and that
creates
as you're saying the atoms don't have
time to arrange the way they would in
the slower Cooling and and so is that
something now is and maybe this leads
into your research is that something
that you can adjust I guess uh you know
based on the heat of the laser based on
can we dive into that a little bit uh
let me let me just develop on that just
a little bit uh so that indeed um
so in metals really the cooling happens
very fast okay why is that because it's
a it's like you you can say wow if fast
cooling is better then why don't we just
you know somehow do fast cooling and
testing right but you cannot you've got
the microscopic part I mean then you
know there's only so fast that you can
take the heat out right and you can take
at least
one hours to cool down whereas here you
basically the laser just hit up a very
tiny spot and yeah locally if not that
spot where the remaining part is called
and then as soon as the laser moves away
then that part is immediately solidifies
right so so that
um so the times goes very fast but also
there's another difference that is the
the lens go is also very small so so
Montana have very high sort of the Rays
but also you have very high spatial
gradients okay and that tends to distort
the lattice and then then that also
contributes to forming a different
microstructure that's fascinating so I
want to come back to that and come back
to it you know in the context of the
class and and how you might help
Engineers or managers who are thinking
about this uh how the class might help
them understand that process and
understand how that might feed into
their decisions around this I wanted to
come back to some of the other uh
promises around this and what you had
said is uh Professor Lewis is the um
the ability to kind of design what you
can imagine and you know one of the
things I I and we had talked about this
earlier is is you had said look a lot of
people are asking you know can I replace
this part with 3D metal 3D printing you
said that's totally the wrong question
what you want to ask is what can I
design you know what can I do with metal
3D printing what are the you know the
possibilities you don't want to
necessarily just use additive
manufacturing or 3D printing to replace
a part you want to think of how you can
redesign that and take advantages of the
uh of the uh the the strength so could
we go into
a little bit of that I know it relates
to this question of the microstructures
but just in terms of Designing a part
can you talk about some of the promises
there and what's exciting about Metal 3D
printing in that context yeah there is a
lot to Embark in that question so let me
first go a step back to the question you
asked way before and you know about you
know whether you can control the heat
yeah
because you know or maybe we want to
control the heat right and so what may
seem as a liability may also be an about
that right so it's a different material
so the question is okay with this
process I can I get this this material
what can I use it for yeah right so if
you start looking at 3D printing in that
way then suddenly you say okay you know
there are a lot a lot more opportunities
already available right and and so
you know the question is again
what can I do with 3D printing instead
of solely replacing a casting process
it's very hard to economically replace a
casting process because it's already
very optimized right so generally 3D
printing has found Niche applications in
things in which you have to manufacture
a few of each Aerospace Industries okay
or for instance a dental
implants or or Bridges or crowns that
are custom made for each customer okay
so those are situations in which it
makes a lot of sense both in from
engineering perspective and economical
and economic perspective to use a 3D
printing process
and it has you know those are indices in
which it's penetrated right SpaceX
manufactures in their rocket engines
right with their own custom-made
cleaning processes
so but at the same time there are other
creative uses of 3D printing in the
higher Mouse the most famous one is is
the one of the GE lip nozzle and it's
you know it's everywhere in the Press
but it's a fascinating story uh you know
they essentially you know when you have
a rocket engine you have to inject a
fuel into the engine and you have a lot
of nozzles that
do that and each nozzle used to be
manufactured with assembling and Welding
20 different parts
to just get one nozzle and you have to
do it for a lot of nozzles right
and you know so what GE did because they
also have a very you know a
bubbling or you know very active
additive manufacturing business they
replace that with a new design that it's
only one part printed once
is we don't have to assemble assemble it
and it is cheaper it lasts longer and is
more efficient okay so that's you know
the the poster boy for ID manufacturing
but then you have even more interesting
things right like for instance a the
company that our colleague Joe DeSimone
started carbon 3D that is here in the
Bay Area
they they created this lattice Soul
shoes for Adidas we have now Adidas is
manufacturing
those so those socials running shoes
right with lots of carbon printers and
the the distinguishing feature of those
shoes is that they sort of have a
tailored a mechanical response for a
shock absorption interesting uh you know
based on what we call lattice instead of
being a homogeneous material it's a
material made of little struts
whose geometrical a configuration
thickness a an arrangement is designed
to have some shock absorption
capabilities and they did the same thing
with radar helmets so they created Parts
in individualized custom-made paths for
real helmets for the NFL right they are
being sold today 3D printed is there a
possibility to do similar uh level of
kind of customization with metal today I
mean is that is that um it sounds like
that's a much more complicated good
process oh no it is yeah for instance in
an industry that hasn't emerged because
the economics of it doesn't seem doesn't
seem to be there yet is of custom-made
knee and hip implants right foreign
foreign I think that in time we're gonna
see a drift towards a custom-made
implants
yeah and that that's interesting that
one comes up a lot is the ability to to
sort of Design This the I guess the
texture on on the surface of the implant
so that the bone can better you know
grow onto the implant oh that's already
been there that's already done that's
called
that is one of the main manufacturing
methods for correspondent I mean is
precisely
but I'm talking about the entire implant
if you have a problem in your knee so
what is your bone I got the best weight
oh boy okay to build the implants so
that okay right so that it perfectly
adjusts to your knee and you have less
chances of uh you know rejecting the
implant and you have best better chances
of walking more naturally okay so that
is a problem that is not you know it
hasn't been perfectly solved
today okay it will be better solved this
at some point it's convenient to to 3D
print the customer
that's interesting okay and we're
getting some you know some some
questions over here uh you know on that
level of you know
you know predicting the state change of
material before it's printed and and and
whether we can keep the metal uh heated
with with microwaves I guess
um but maybe before we jump into those
can we um
can we talk a little bit more then about
the challenges with metal in particular
professors Ty so like what are maybe
coming back to those parameters not
around design but around where these
questions are going around the material
and thinking about the material itself
and and how you can uh you know
predicting it understanding it so one
thing we had talked about before before
uh this began was
you know one thing that comes up and
maybe we can get into part of uh uh what
is the powder bed Fusion we can get to
that a little bit because that'll be the
focus of the class but one of the
challenges with that is that there there
can be these these defects these defects
which make it sometimes uh
you know more risk with failure or or
fatigue strain and those kinds of things
it sounds like that is still an issue
can so can you maybe talk a little bit
more about the challenges around working
with metal in particular and predicting
and understanding what's what's
happening there right so so I guess I
can
this gets to basically the first
question yeah okay so can we you know
predict the state change of metal before
it's printed yeah so and and for example
like then we talk about this fantastic
opportunity of you can form many
different kinds of microstructures right
microstructure in some sense is
basically the same as how the defects
are arranged right so I think the short
answer well by somewhere in between yes
and no okay yeah so what I mean is that
um there's this huge
um body of knowledge of called physical
Metallurgy okay
um that has been basically wrong for
decades and then that's how you know we
continue to have you know people you
know have new Alloys design you know the
super Alloys that you use in the engine
uh you know over the you know the five
decades you know they get better and
better I mean those are not Metals 3D
printed right but but basically in order
to accomplish that people really have um
made a lot of into the advances on our
understanding of how you know how
microstructure change how you can
influence that by like heat and
processing and all that so so those are
the material science aspects right and
and that Foundation does not change I
mean basically it's like it's going to
be the same
kind of players in there okay so if it's
still okay the steel has FCC BCC phase
Okay so we've got to deal with those
okay and then you have grain boundaries
and you have you know dislocations so so
basically
so so we can actually people can use a
lot of this knowledge right and and
um a lot of this uh so the metal 3D
printing are very analogous to welding
because it's literally like you just
weld everywhere okay
um so so basically a lot of knowledge
can be used and to to make sort of
General prediction you do want to apply
those and so that you get an idea
um
roughly speaking you know which
trajectory the material is taking as
it's cooling down right
um so so that I guess is kind of
a lot of what we want to cover in the
class so that you basically get
everybody some general understanding of
what to expect right but I don't think
we're at the level
we mean in the community
that that we know precisely like if you
know if you do exactly this kind of
laser printing then then this will be
exactly the microstructure but this is
just too rich right but I think so
that's like a research question right
now but but with time right then our
prediction will become better and better
right but ultimately it's going to be
using all of those knowledge and also
cut out your printed parts and put in a
microscope and then use that you to
update our understanding of how the
microstructure evolved so even within
industry there's probably a research
element as you're developing the parts
is understanding looking at those
microstructures being able and I guess
one advantage of this is you don't have
to invest in all the tooling necessary
for casting you can kind of iterate
through it a couple times to understand
what that structure is maybe or
it's harder to do than to than to say
yeah okay yeah yeah that is it's been a
lot of alchemy in some sense learning
how to print the part yeah you know
right now it's you know it takes a
number of iterations to get to an
acceptable Park and it's part and it's
Guided by by knowledge of the open icon
so it's this combination of kind of the
fundamental science and then some
Empirical research of doing it and and
then
improving on the process and there are
components that are better than others
and we're probably not the most advanced
yet I mean there's a lot of knowledge
that is proprietary yeah that's
interesting
um and and so uh
you know one of the things that you
mentioned in in there the the mechanics
and computation group mentioned in some
of their Research into this is and I I'm
this is just a personal interest to me
is it sounds like you can actually
potentially tune electromagnetic uh um
properties is that can we what does that
mean and can you and I saw there was a
recent research I think done here at
Stanford on this in particular for
ranging Parts like that maybe one in
award or a grant
yeah is any any thoughts on that or any
is that something that's new or is that
something that we've been able to do
with casting or is that that a real I
see okay okay
so yeah maybe maybe what I have in mind
is not necessarily the
in terms of moderating the electromagnet
in a way but but but but maybe this is
still something sort of relevant that is
uh you know like I said you want to say
earlier metal M can open up new
possibilities right that are not you
know even possible before so so we're
not even uh sort of trying to duplicate
a previous uh to the part right so so
basically I guess there is this
interesting story about
um you know
maybe am can have interesting sort of
solutions for your application to
electric motors right okay so like I
don't know whether you ever open up a
electric motor before that's okay okay
if you open up you should see their
coils yeah and usually a multiple three
of them and then there are coils one out
around some some core okay so so what
we're trying to do there is to basically
make an electrical
electromagnet basically those coils if
it is current goes really become a
magnet so that is allow you to basically
convert electric energy into pores
and then so so basically what is the
coils around round up about is that that
is the iron core so the purpose of that
is to amplify the mechanic field but
generated by the coil
but then if you put closer attention
look at them more carefully then then
that core is not a solid piece of iron
it's actually made of many stacks well I
don't know why is that is because
usually this motor you run it with high
frequency currents and then the so the
magnetic field changes back and forth
very fast and when magnetic field
changes that produces a a current
exercise your core and that's called the
eddy current and then that can beat you
Heating and displayed energy right okay
so so what we want is a a core that is
magnetic but kind of not conducting so
what they do is that they cut it into
many many slices of the current can go
like that so it can only be confined
within each thin slice and that's
interesting okay but the thing is that
if you want to run the motor at higher
and higher frequency then you you want
to get this layers thinner and thinner
and that becomes more and more costly
right so so then say okay this is not
what we want ultimately we want a
different material like we want a
material in which
is magnetic but it's not you know
conducting right so so you basically
ideally what you want is is called a
magnetic composite you you want
basically give a magnetic domains that
are you know separate okay so you don't
want a big piece
so the question is hey can you make that
in metal 3D printing right so you just
print the part and then it's just like
that right so it turns out it's possible
so uh this uh one of our colleagues at
Switzerland actually demonstrated this
recently so so basically we talk about
you know iron iron can have different
places right
the the common one is called the artist
and the cubic phase where that's
magnetic okay but you also notice that
the stainless steel is not magnetic the
magnet does not stick to it the
stainless steel is actually the sort of
iron but it has a different crystal
structure it's called face and Equipment
FCC so let's see if the arrangement BCC
is magnetic absence is non-magnetic
right so wow what if you can you know
these are just two different
microstructures right so so what if you
can control it so that at some point
because of my condition this condition
is PCC and magnetic and then the other
point is not magnetic right so what
people have demonstrated is that you can
have you know
as you print you can change the
parameters so that some Regional
magnetic some original non-magnetic so
it's a basically effectively print the
composite a magnetic composite uh
interesting and wow okay so I guess
that's one way you can have the effect
on the magnetic property of material
that's really exciting that's very neat
and that's something that wasn't
available obviously through traditional
casting methods right there's no way no
you can't do that right yeah you cannot
do it in that controlled way yes I said
you can do you can mix particles in
into Matrix and things like that but
this you know should very fine control
of where the material will be magnetic
or not
and in fact you see once you can do that
you can say wow right maybe I
because you literally can uh specify
which point you want to be magnetic and
which one you want to not be magnetic
right so maybe you can arrange them not
just necessary in a regular array or
whatever way that's that's usual your
needs so in other words the the
structure of it as well can be very
complicated in terms of where the points
are it gives you the freedom to design
basically optimize
so and maybe that's a good segue into
the class itself so this is you know
this is can we talk a little bit more so
you have a class on metal 3D printing
that you're going to be teaching here at
Stanford as I said uh earlier it is open
to to enrollment by remote students as
well uh Professionals in the area or
globally so can you you know what is
maybe Professor Lou if you could just
start out what is the kind of the
Genesis of the class and what are you
trying to accomplish with it
yeah so we you know when I started in
metatar 3D printing I realized I had to
learn a lot of things I wasn't very
familiar with you know I just saw that
when I was a student but I had I had not
used that right and if I wanted to talk
to people that were doing the printing I
I just need to know yeah and so I said
okay imagine that that is somebody in an
organization that is starting to print
or is printing with Metals right
how can I help that person communicate
with his colleagues or her or her
colleagues colleagues okay and so the
class is designed a giving the students
a broad understanding of a lot of
different topics that are involved in
metatary degree
it also it's also designed to give you a
perspective on you know to teach you how
to print as well so that's the practice
part of the class
but it's it it tries to the class will
also give you the science behind the
meta 3D printing so that
you know such person can participate
easily in a conversation in which that
are microscopies metallurgists you know
there are CAD designers there are
printer planners there are operators of
the printer
a
and so essentially a holistic view of
the process of metativity
and they can talk more about other
classes yeah I would love me and one
thing that's interesting and I think we
again the society came up uh earlier is
in one of our earlier conversations I'm
I'm seeing you know on my side here
obviously I'm not an engineer but I'm I
work with a lot of the class the
engineers who are here teaching classes
and it seems more and more that these
holistic classes are necessary because
you're bringing so many even within
engineering I mean it's terrifying to me
to think that someone who has a PHD and
they've been a professors like that
there's so much I had to learn that just
even you know to understand and be able
to talk to people it just it it's just
interesting to me this is more of an
observation than question but just it's
interesting how important these kind of
holistic classes are becoming it seems
and I mentioned before we see this in
the robotics as well as is Professor
saying you can't just be the sensor
person you have to understand exactly
but the decision planning is you have to
understand all these parts you may be
focusing on the Metallurgy you may be
focusing on the design but you need to
have this larger this larger knowledge
base in order to make informed decisions
um yeah I would love to hear maybe what
are what are some of the you know what
are some of the can you give us some
details about what are that kind of yeah
well I mean the only the good thing is
that because the class tries to cover
such a broad range is that we're not
going to be the only ones teaching it
yeah we have a lot of very interesting
invited guest speakers for instance in
the second day of the class we're going
to have a lecture by Benny Bueller who's
the CEO and founder of Bello 3D company
that manufactures unique 3D printer meta
3D printers here in the Bay Area but now
uh you know it's a it's in the New York
Stock Exchange okay so he's gonna give
us a perspective of where the 3D print
meta creates the market is today what
are the needs what are customers want
and where does he see this going forward
right so that's just an overview of
where we should expect yeah the the
generally the industry to move them then
we're going to have a either Hardy
kavaria or psychopal nature from carbon
3D who are in charge of all the software
infrastructure for their 3D printing
which is a polymer 3D printing but they
they are thinking about okay now that we
can't 3D print
what are the tools that we need to take
advantage of
of the freedom that we have right for
instance if I have a geometry can I
lattice it can I fill it with a lattice
okay can I do topology optimization on
that can I do both at the same time so
they are building those tools for people
to use so they're going to software
tools yeah software tools so we're gonna
we're gonna hear from them you can also
want to learn how to use you know
related tools not exactly the cargo
tools okay when I have also
the
Mania Matthews from it was the
he was I don't know he's not the
director he was you know one of the key
people that uh leading the activities of
mental tree building on Lawrence they
were more National Lab it's probably the
largest organization in the U.S in terms
of activity metal 3D printing uh we also
we also want to have somebody from Xerox
Park he's a metallurgist he's going to
tell us about the families of Alloys
that are suitable for intact 3D printing
a and then others that are still you
know being invited
so the class is aimed again at giving it
a holistic perspective of
of where things are right now no matter
the printing
I'm giving
essentially and you know relying not
only on you know our limited knowledge
but also a little bit on people that are
out there in the field
trying to make it work
is there anything you would add yeah
yeah so also you know as you were saying
like
there's so many things involved right
and and I I don't feel uh so bad about
not knowing everything in fact uh so so
some of the lectures will also be uh
given by our collaborators on campus
there are experts on lasers and experts
on capitalization of the of the prince
so so basically you know laser is
something I mean that's so outside of my
area of expertise right so uh but you
know it's a very important part of this
whole uh Enterprise right so so
basically
um you know then the students can hear
directly from the experts I mean so in
terms of something like a laser is is
what's important is just the kind of
layers of the properties I mean
adjusting the the Optics right I mean
these are actually very strong lasers
not the laser pointer so so you you want
them to be you know reliable and and
then um you know all the little details
I mean the small details right so like
the utilizers on for too long maybe you
know only the things will hit up and and
then you were the lands were changed the
beam a little bit right and that just
the Optics of that right so and then
you're you're in the end the parts of
precision is not coming okay right
that's interesting so even you have to
understand you're not just predicting
what's going to happen to to the you
know the the powder that you're you're
you're you're training the laser on but
there it may affect kind of how the
machine itself operates it's like it's
like driving a car right yeah you can
just drive it but you know sometimes you
have to know a little bit about how it
works right yeah well it sounds like a
little bit more than that
I like I like the fact that skiing and
driving are analogous have now are now
in a position in which you actually
don't need to know much right yeah but
it used to be that you know you should
be ready to fix them right and so yeah I
mean you need to know how the process
works what the limits of the of the
machine are because the problem is that
you know they operate or whoever
operates the machine should know that
but if you have something it's not
working well you need to be aware that
that this could be a problem and again
I'm coming back to this holistic idea of
understanding how things
what the what the main issues are when
you 3D print Metals right so that you
can actually you know
solve the problems when they appear
and be able to correctly identify the
problem it sounds like that might not
even the thing you're thinking about
that the laser itself has changed the
property is the laser changing if it's
on too long or something like yeah yeah
that's interesting
um and then in terms of will you also
get into you talked about the software
which I assume is is used in part to
design but also to predict is that right
now a pretty as I've read this as well
as like you've got to use CAD to design
and another one to predict the
properties and another one and each time
you change your design you're working
through three different software systems
that don't necessarily talk to each
other is that still a problem it sounds
like someone's working on solving it is
that still a problem is that something
you get into a little bit in the class
in terms of the
well I mean the the connection between
cat and optimization of the design you
know mechanical optimization electric
optimization that that link is is a
little bit closer now to things like
Fusion 360 and you know for instance the
tools that carbon is carbon 3D is
working or many other initiatives
and in terms of trying to understand the
mechanical properties of the bar that's
very that's there's nobody who does that
really well these days so yeah that's
that's a niche part and often uh you
know it's not that much as it used as
much in Industry that that's not
critical
critically used
right because in terms of the kind of
product I guess right now what people
can do is that there's some general
Trends right as a rule of thumbs so so
basically if you
um
if you do a modeling of the thermal uh
process I mean the basically the
temperature history of everything and
then you of your mature point then you
there's some guidance on what you should
expect right
but but I right um it's still at a
rather qualitative level so that you
don't say oh there's a software I press
a button I mean right but maybe in five
ten years with some products would
appear can we walk through maybe a few
of the other things so we we have kind
of thinking about the class but also
just thinking generally if someone who's
listening right now who's thinking about
Metal 3D printing or involved is kind of
there's there's you know in general the
kind of the business what's happening in
the future what are the niche there's
understanding you know what's possible
what's possible as a designer right in
terms of Imagine these parts but then it
sounds like you need to understand
you need to understand something about
the machine itself the properties of
lasers you need to also understand a lot
about the properties of metals that
you're dealing with
and how they behave under
uh under high heat and rapid cooling
what are some of the other aspects of
this that you that you cover what are I
mean what about the post-processing what
about
um you know testing I mean you know what
are some of the other things that you
think are important for people to be
thinking about what are who are some of
the other people who are involved in
these kinds of processes that are
important to bring into the conversation
during the class so in the class we are
going to have you know the class has two
lanes one lane is with labs and one lane
without Labs
all students will go at least in theory
through all the process through you know
the beginning to the end of coming up
with an idea designing a bot remitting
it for printing thinking a little bit
about the material properties that one
would get
post-processing it
essentially evaluating how it looks like
right the students I will take the lab
will be able to do this in practice as
well okay and
and so you know through the classy
structure in a way that we start from
software we go through this
scientific Foundation okay then we go
into the more heuristic way of finding
how to print
okay there's no recipe it's just a way
to proceed right and then we go into a
final project in which we're going to
try to do topology optimization of a of
a part for a function okay as a
practical way of applying these things
um I don't know if I answered yeah yeah
I think yeah
so so I guess
um
you know
there's the we talk about the what the
metal goes through right uh uh you know
Cooling and all that but then you know
sometimes
um you know you may want to do a
post-treatment but uh to to modify the
problem a little bit and also another
aspect uh would be you know what are the
different characterization tools
that can be
um that are commonly used right now
right to to sort of try to diagnose uh
if is everything okay microstructurally
or identity problems so it's so in other
words there's also maybe a post
treatment a post-processing
part of that is just it's probably the
Practical stuff polishing finishing you
know cleaning and some of it it sounds
like can actually also adjust the
properties right like you can put it in
the oven and then sort of bake a little
bit uh so so that you see you go down
really fast right but it's okay that
that was fast okay but then I can kind
of raise the temperature globally a
little bit right and then let it slowly
cool down and and that is you know has
been used for conventional capacity
Parts as well so but but you can do that
for for Metals really bring the parts to
sort of modify the product a little bit
regarding the characterization so we're
gonna another product we're gonna learn
in the class is uh you know the
principle of scanning electron
microscopy and Optical microscopy and
okay how do you
prepare those images and once you have
the image how do you interpret so and
this is what's happening after you've
created it when you're trying to
understand
quality the quality of your part right
so you want to see how many points do I
have you know what type of
microstructure do I have generate the
Martin side right so you know this is
part of being able to have a
conversation right and interpreting the
data that would be used in case of
assessing the quality of about right
essentially so you know earlier on we're
talking about predicting these and it
sounds like there's some of that's going
into it in terms of planning it but a
lot of it is also understanding after
the fact and we got this question about
you know the fatigue properties I assume
some of that's just going to have to
come out through looking at the
particular microstructure and then
testing it as well yes
it is like that
and can I ask you know so I think we're
we're nearing the end of time so I think
but maybe one last question for you
excuse me um my side is
the machines themselves as we think
about industrial purposes or scaling
these how how sensitive are you know
it's
you're working at you know when you're
talking about what you're doing you're
working at a very small level how
sensitive are those to the machines
themselves how much does the machine
itself influence you know what what the
results will be and and how much I
imagine that may be something that comes
into this class as well is that you
could have 10 machines and two of them
are finicky and they behave slightly
differently and creating different
things I mean is that is that um a
reality now and and is that something
that will go away in the future or is
that always just going to be probably a
part of this process because of the the
what the level that you're working with
yeah so unfortunately you know you have
two similar machines you say okay they
are the same machine and they actually
can get different results okay and this
is because we are not yet at the staging
which we really know exactly all the
details that affecting the quality of
the part that you produce so often what
people do is once they know how to
manufacture a parting machine they just
don't touch the machine
we just manufacture it okay right but
this is going to improve in the future
as more sensors are included in the
into these machines and more data
science is added an experience is gained
machine manufacturers will will
understand how to certify the the
quality of their products better yeah
yeah
so it's I think that the showdowns are
requesting it right yeah the machines
are very Affinity
um so so that
um you know when we started right we
were trying to say okay you try to
compare our model predictions yes with
the you know what happens and that's
when we realized we have to have our own
machine because
um at least you can you know try to you
know get to the bottom of what's
happening right so it seems like I think
the screen is improving is that the
reportability should be you know getting
better and better there's no mystery
right so it's just that sometimes some
things that you didn't suspect could
cause the difference for example
um
you know if you change the powder and
but the powder may have a different
impurity content than a previous batch
of powder you have and that can make all
the difference right so
um so basically you know I think with
time uh then people realize you know
that these are the things that you
should check right and then you because
you basically have one uncontrolled
parameter then you didn't know about and
then that could make all the difference
so this is coming back to those
heuristics it's just the process of
doing it you learn how to check the
Purity or or and I I've read a lot about
also the grain size and I assume that
was known that right
this is why the class is called the
science and the practice Yeah meta 3D
printing so that you know we don't try
to mean that we understand everything
there's things that we understand and
that's good there are things you just
know yeah
um
yeah but I I just want to have one more
thought because
you know if you look at let's say
casting or metal forming people also
took a lot of time to learn how to do it
right I mean and there is a lot of Art
in doing that as well right yeah but in
melaton people have a thousand years too
yeah yeah I understand I understand but
that's true so but you know I
I think that one of the problems you
know there is a question here what's
preventing 3D printing from the most by
why they're available but my thinking is
that you know right now you know we're
thinking how they printed us like the
print that you have the injured printer
that you may have at home right that you
just send the print that it plates
that's not the case generally you know
you need a special operator for the
machine and the person has to be trained
so even if you buy a machine from a
company that person has to have intimate
knowledge of how that works right so
that's a big a tall order to to overcome
right I think that that's a big problem
and so we are potentially seeing a shift
from you know companies buying machines
to companies offering services in which
they print because they will know how to
how to pray okay this will take a little
bit of time until the best business
model falls into place
okay interesting yeah so and the other
thing is that
you know the current generation of
students are only starting to learn oh
yeah I can 3D print I can design with
this Freedom imagine a person has been
designing for 30 years and know that you
know they had to design and they have to
put you know you know a hole to put the
ball there with a knot to connect the
two parts because and now he's oh no I
can't do it with 3D printing well I mean
that's a manual transition that takes
it's not easy to make right right so
it's also a generational transition
right so I think we're gonna see more
and more applications as the people who
are now is at school start populating
the ranks of engineering firms and my
understanding is that was always an
issue and then you know someone fresh
out of engineering school sends a
designed or machinist or someone who
specializes in casting they're like this
is you can't do this right this isn't
you know it's not incredible they may be
right I always have a lot of respect for
people who have a lot of experience yeah
um and you know we had this this last
question that maybe it actually kind of
relates to these things is there is one
other thing a constraint on this which
is
it had whatever you're going to print
it's got to fit in the metal 3D printer
right so that's still a I know there are
some maybe polymer printers that can do
car bodies I mean what are the size that
we're generally dealing with I guess
right now well that one you know yes or
no so indeed for the part of a fusion
indeed okay there's a build area of
build volume so you found it you know
print within the container that has the
powder but but the other Technologies
where you print something that's much
bigger than a printer interesting that's
I saw this space I mean I've got
activity ads I mean they print the whole
rocket right
um I mean then the rock is huge I mean
you don't want to have a printer that's
even bigger than the rocket so how do
they do that is literally bucket is very
big but it's a thin shell so so they're
literally just uh you know but that's a
different technology so you just extrude
uh you know things uh you know around
the shell and in fact in fact the
printer doesn't exist over there and the
shell rotates and to get printed right
so so you can have a enormous
um you know product with a printer
that's just extruding the filament
that's actually not smaller it's it's
not the exactly screwing it's similar to
that yeah all right yeah and it's called
relativity space
because we miss SpaceX and
this is great I I think we'll leave it
there there's more questions that came
in
a lot more we could talk about but uh
but and thank you so much both of you
for joining me today to talk a little
bit about the class and talk about the
future metal 3D printing thank you
everyone who joined us today for your
questions and for for being here and
hopefully we'll see you in the class
yeah hopefully thank you thank you